madame la Première ministre vous
qualifiez votre projet de réforme des
retraites de justes solidaires et
pérenne la réalité n'est pourtant pas
celle-ci pourquoi votre projet est un
juste puisque vous allongez la durée de
cotisation à 43 sa nualité pardon et là
je n'ai pas en retraite à 64 ans ce sont
principalement les ouvriers les employés
et les femmes qui seront pénalisés votre
projet est injuste puisque les salariés
les mieux rémunérés vont davantage
davantage capitaliser pour leur retraite
tandis que la grande majorité des
travailleurs ne pourront pas bénéficier
du minimum de pensées de pension à 1200
euros brut votre projet est injuste car
vous allez appauvrir les seniors qui
seront plus longtemps au chômage et que
vous avez précarisé à l'extrême votre
projet ne sera pas pérenne car vous ne
changez pas de logiciel du financement
d'autres solutions existent pourtant il
suffirait et ce n'est qu'un exemple de
taxer de 2% la fortune des milliardaires
vous avez versé 160 milliards de roses
entreprises en contrepartie pendant la
crise de la covid CE quoi qu'il en coûte
ne peut-il être décidé pour garantir une
vraie retraite en bonne santé une
retraite sereine c'est un choix de
société qui est à faire un monde de
juste répartition des richesses pour
l'intérêt général ou celui d'un CAC 40
gorgé de dividendes madame la Première
ministre vous avez choisi alors qu'il
n'y a pas d'urgence extrême d'utiliser
une loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour restreindre
les débats parlementaires à 20 jours à
l'Assemblée nationale et 15 au Sénat
c'est un super 49,3 que vous avez
dégainé des voies s'élèvent pour
souligner l'inconstitutionnalité de
votre démarche madame la Première
ministre c'est parce que cette réforme
voulue par Macron est injuste qu'elle
frappe les plus faible qu'elle est
rejetée très massivement avec l'ensemble
des syndicats la société tout entière
est vend debout et seule le Medef et
Monsieur Ciotti vous soutiennent pas
encore madame la Première ministre nous
relayons ici le vaste mouvement qui
s'enclenche et de demain le 19 janvier
nous serons dans la rue avec le peuple
qui exige le retrait de votre projet
[Musique]